valérie bénaïm oui vous m'aviez défier
sur slam l'émission de cyril tout à fait
c'est quoi l'histoire alors qu'est ce
qui se passe mais écoutez vous avez fait
un peu le malin lors d'une précédente
émission bien sûr parce que vous disiez
être un homme de lettres je vais vous
est pris au mot vous disais que j'étais
cruciverbiste bien sûr vous adoriez les
mots croisés et c'est donc j'ai voulu
savoir si une petite partie de slam tous
les deux à moi vous posant des questions
et vous y répondant vous releviez le
défi vous aviez dit oui alors juste
avant valérie oui juste vous avez encore
vous avez encore rendez vous chez le
dentiste je dis je crois oui c'est jeudi
la quatrième phase est la dernière alors
normalement la dernière fois je crois
qu'il le vit comment patoche votre
amoureux de 15h et dentistes ouais bah
ils se feront pas on ne vient pas ce que
j'ai trouvé des photos de votre dentiste
le docteur abitbol coin et je suis pas
sûr que patoche soit très content que
vous alliez c'est pas fini regarder
voilà c'est grave mais cette barrière
alors avis à nîmes on joue donc h la wii
donc vous attaquez vous relevez de
l'avenir c'est quoi c'est une grille de
mots croisés et greg taylor simplement
des définitions alors des mois à trouver
allez-y
c'est parler dans les règles allez on y
va on voit les machines on est d'accord
au dollar ban entendu on va démarrer par
une première définition
j'enlève mon oreiller sipa oulémas bah
oui bien sûr on va démarrer par une
premiers mots extrêmement simple si je
vous dis tout simplement si ce n'est pas
maman s'est pris pour un abruti
non mais c'est pas choisi pour
interpréter mais je me suis dit on va
tester niveau si je n'ai pas un moment
c'est papa papa c'est la paperasse et
une bonne 3 pas par papa en fait ce
serait bien non c'est pas évident on
démarre doucement je te paye vidé mardi
soir démarre encore avec un tout petit
peu vous êtes d'accord pour que la
deuxième définition cyril
concentrez-vous définition suivante le
nom scientifique du cerisier à homer bla
vertical on aperçoit là ça fait peur de
ceux de minuscules jacques monsieur 14
janvier la maire albert albert oui ce
qui se passe
bah je sais les plombs vous êtes vous
avez fait nous sur easy ou pas pourquoi
vous y connaissez vous
bah oui mais c'est cool de cerisy sheff
nsr asus monsieur le ceras us c'est une
plante qu'il faut tailler entre 18
heures et 20 heures uniquement mash up
batoche très sympa merci bergé matthieu
pigasse et mise en scène dans la
démission pas et demander quoi il
demandé quoi que je repose la question
je lui ai demandé définit la définition
est la suivante le nom scientifique du
cerisier cyril serait pas le ser asus
[Applaudissements]
m'étonnant ou et d'en maîtriser le
calendrier en plus merci merci monsieur
cabinet comme ça mais franchement là
vous bluffer il était dans la brique à
d'autres avancent alors et dans la la je
triche pas sans rigoler je montrais y
aller au calme maintenant
ben là je ne triche pas dernier mot vous
l'avez vous regardez votre votre grille
elle correspond à la ligne numéro deux
d'accord définition dispositif
d'allumage de moteur à explosion
dispositif d'allumage de moteur à
explosion
oui oui j'arrive de minutes chaudes
radio à cela mais j'arrive 2010 ces
enfants qui revient tout de suite une
urgence
ça doit être hyper important pour qu'ils
nous quittent
qu'est ce qui se passe est en panne et
vous aider ou pas lady je regardais ça
[Musique]
m'aurait la brèche face à ces
problématiques
bah ouais bah c'est ça c'est la marelle
je vois ça j'ai compris c'est pas celle
des locaux c'est le cocktail d'alcools
charest que tu le maire ce qu'il a dit
elle coule des locaux c'est quoi une
belle coffre et le quotidien sur la tête
de l'alcool l'humeur est parti j'avais
des amis que thomas marty mcfly et
c'était moi l'histoire déjà là-bas d'or
lac la question merci depuis pas merci
pour eux déjà ça revient sur voirie
gentil à vous on était en plein jeu la
question c'était la définition de
dispositif d'allumage de moteur à
explosion cyril celle d'al qods aviez
vous aviez enlever votre oreillette donc
il n'y a aucune tricherie aucune miette
et je vous dis on n'est plus du tout la
dodo j'ai foncé
on